[Music]
people got have understand you got an
attack attack attack certain individuals
you don't attack you run from I'm
talking I see and believe me I will I'll
put you down quickly
like don't you know you're gonna get the
best sniper in the game huh
violent speed momentum whatever game
that I'm playing make sure you're not
playing that game
what dr. dizzy smacks talking about it's
some paintings whoa baby
[Music]
oh my god he kind of nothing these guys
are nothing in the game
I'm the bath guy doctor disrespect beam
wasn't always the two-time champ on the
2-time 1993 1994 blockbuster video game
champion in the online gaming community
the face of twitch and a man with
self-proclaimed venomous gaming
athleticism who kind of resembles an ad
style action star he was born on March
10 1982 and his life in videogames
started as well a joke my gamertag was
diarrhea panic and I was online with a
few buddies and they have ridiculous
names as well guy was a varsity
basketball player in university who
spent his free time dominating in halo
and other first-person shooter games he
birthd is now heralded alter-ego dr
disrespect while playing halo 2 on xbox
with friends yeah aren't you the one
that needs to tighten his braces up
idiot back then
game developers still believed proximity
comms were a good idea so if you were
close to an enemy you could actively
taunt them as you killed them you turn
around turn around too late mistake and
it was in Halo 2 where that gravely
eighties action star voice was born the
docs tarted his assault on the online
gaming world by uploading short YouTube
clips of him well disrespecting his
opponents I literally love the stairs go
into the house and give you a root canal
with bullets
you may take it B because b is my and
like any top content creator it didn't
hurt that he was absolutely lethal at
the games he was playing knock-knock the
same doclets oh yes it was on January
5th 2010 that he first started posting
to YouTube in conjunction with his
college roommates
she's just blessed to be around some
good friends that we always had a camera
around us and then you know we could
just shoot at all times and I could just
cut it up throw it up on YouTube boom we
got something he generally post gameplay
footage and perform voiceover in his
doctor persona at the same time he
changed his halo in-game username to
doctor disrespect and that's where the
lines between guy beam and the doc began
to blur so I guess with the creation of
that gamertag came the creation of the
character perhaps maybe the most apt
thing about his moniker is the word
disrespect because that's how he built
his brand the entire origin of his
alter-ego stemmed from him making plays
in game in order to best embarrass his
opponent the doctor was about disrespect
from the beginning oh you're gonna fire
bullets at me if you're gonna kill the
doctor
negative it's freezing outside here let
me warm you up what's he done and I put
all three of you down on January 11th
2010 doctor disrespect began to up his
content creation game by creating his
own YouTube channel with dr. disrespects
talking about it's some pain deliverance
he was playing call of duty modern
warfare 3 at the time and built his
content around while blaming his
opponents now that I'm in control the
same story it's time to dominate your
sister oh there she is snipers what
sniper wants to stand back it's a
mistake he'd also collaborate with other
YouTube personalities with larger
followings by calling them out and
playing with them I reached out to mr.
360 games you know said hey check out my
video if you don't I'd cut you up you
know like one of those type of vehicles
and he actually viewed it liked it and
did a shout out in one of his videos
that sort of jump-started my my run dr.
D immediately started to foster
attention his antics were the
intensification of the way the world
looked at the male gamer stereotype of
the time and his flame first approach
was pretty hilarious on my body that's
on my body the doc started creating
content for a popular gaming channel
called machinima after his first wave of
popularity and it was then when his
following started to balloon for the
first time but then almost as quickly as
his YouTube success began dr. disrespect
disappeared on February 22nd 2011 his
YouTube channel and the followers of his
impeccable venomous video game
athleticism were left without the
content they were hungry for guy being
put down his second life as the doctor
to fulfill dreams of his own a career in
the game design industry I didn't really
know what was where I wanted to go I
just know I've always wanted to get into
the
videogame industry the interactive
entertainment industry and but like I
had no experience beam joined
sledgehammer games on March 16th 2011
the game development company responsible
for multiple Call of Duty titles as its
community manager I mean the only thing
that really made sense to me possibly
become a community manager but even in
this new path in his life it was the
doctor that built his name in the gaming
community to bolster his application at
sledgehammer but my experiences that
I've that I've gained in the creation of
the doctor character from a social media
perspective growing the Twitter and the
Facebook and how to grow a YouTube
channel how to read feedback engage with
your with your fans your audience and at
the same time to be able to be involved
in all of this and understand videogames
it just made sense after some time as
community manager beam was promoted to
level designer for Call of Duty advanced
warfare where he participated in the
development of seven of the maps in the
game
I designed half the mass for Call of
Duty advanced warfare multiplayer and
also helped create a lot of the high
level pillars first the studio during
his time at sledgehammer guy created a
justin.tv account and tried streaming a
few times as the doc now as you might
imagine when you've built a personality
as more or less a second version of
yourself like guy beam did with doctor
disrespect it's kind of a challenge to
keep that guy logged away so in 2015 guy
beam with his job at sledgehammer and
unleashed doctor disrespect it began
with some YouTube warnings about his
return my doctor disrespect
and as you know we've been away from the
YouTube community for quite a while now
but I'm here to tell you I'm back and I
ain't messin around and then on March
21st 2016 the man we've come to know as
the face of twitch began streaming
full-time the doctors been preparing
himself for his free entrance into the
online gaming community maybe more than
any other streamer Doc's popularity
skyrocketed with the development of the
battle royale format doc was given early
access to H on z1 the zombie themed
battle royale that was the first of the
genre to make headway and it's here
where Doc's love for battle Royales
began they were challenging had enough
downtime to support his streaming and he
could make his signature bad-mouthing a
big part of his play style sorry Timmy
got a punk [ __ ] get out of my face I'm
a six foot eight powerhouse ain't
nothing because I like to remind you
little chubby cheeked wannabe unathletic
pigeon takes Brittany gamers right what
the two times all about
forty-four Jeannie come on come on you
tell me to go blow your nose while
streaming h1z1 doc was averaging around
five to ten thousand viewers at a time
and his stream was growing rapidly but
if h1z1 was the surprising opener of dr.
disrespects jumping into streaming
celebration player unknowns
battlegrounds was the main attraction
it's hard to understate the impact that
pub G had on the streaming landscape
battle Royales and specifically pub G
rewarded streamers with flashy
highlights and clippable moments for a
maximum social media content and to that
extent pub G and dr. disrespects
couldn't be a better match that's
talking about huh are you kidding me huh
whoa baby
are you kidding me huh are you joking
with my mind I really am the best in
this game during the summer of 2017
Doc's average viewership reaches highest
30,000 he had acquired his nickname as
the face of twitch and received industry
awards for both streamer of the year and
gamer of the year the Internet twitch
gaming and dr. disrespect were now
synonymous as climbed a mountain let's
dominate violence speed and momentum and
guess what ret the tippity-top of them
now
but really Bubba really only halfway up
baby he donned a thick mustache and
dollar-store sunglasses and people loved
it what are you thinking like don't you
know you're gonna get the best sniper in
the game huh
okay give you $100 if he hit this shot
headshot has to be a job
that's far okay let me get ya this is a
tower right but then one day guy beam
broke character as you guys know I have
a beautiful family and a wife and kid
and I want to be transparent that I've
been unfaithful his admission was of
course devoid of the pompous charisma of
the doctor and featured bashfulness far
removed from the usual attitude that
people have come to expect from the
twitch channel and I'm probably gonna be
taking some time away take time off so
after his short Frank admission of guilt
doctor disrespect left twitch that's it
doc
respect has spent a lot of time as
twitches darling but even at the height
of his success he's been the target of
heavy scrutiny in the same way that he
acts as a mirror image of the
archetypical gamer he's also a symbol of
some of gaming's most criticized
characteristics his onstream personality
is hyper masculine in nature he's been
criticized for being racially
insensitive on multiple occasions and
called offensive on countless others
it's often hard to get a read on the doc
but despite his personas brash nature
he's not devoid of flashes of empathy
kindness and the familial community
building we see from many top streamers
I realized I've provided an outlet for a
lot of people that are dealing with a
lot of hardships and it makes me proud
[Music]
as 2018 began more than a month had
passed since the doctors last stream and
twitches hero was nowhere to be found
late January brought signs of Doc's
return and rumblings around social media
and a small YouTube teaser marked his
return for early February and then on
February 5th 2018 doctor disrespect
returned I have a plate in a long time
I'm literally I literally just just woke
up out of the waterbed press the start
streaming button and here we are and he
broke twitch right in half
setting a new mark for concurrent
viewership on an individual's twitch
channel at three hundred and eighty
eight thousand viewers you're looking at
the face of twitch and ladies and
gentlemen the arena is wide open doctors
making sure he didn't miss a step
doesn't miss a groove people want the
360 to finish off the game people want
the 360 to finish off the game what's
doctor gonna do this guy's got a sniper
just like that ladies and gentlemen
first game of the day first game of the
year and what do we do ladies and
gentlemen 12 kills a winner winner
chicken dinner my god during that
hallowed February the dock was at full
capacity guy beam was a thing of the
past
he had gimmicks he had flash and it was
all on level 100 he averaged a
career-high of more than 50,000 viewers
at a time since then he stayed steady
around 20 to 25,000 doctor disrespect
has become an integral part of the
modern day twitch ecosystem he's joined
the likes of shroud and Chad who stayed
loyal to pub G
while the mainstream has shifted gears
to fortnight I don't necessarily play it
all the time I just haven't gotten into
it enough yet but you know I'd hate to
play a guy who's as good as me or as
equal as me yeah and he has the same
weapon as me but guess what he has the
gold weapon
he's a moniker for the old guard of the
video game world and his loyalty and
consistency has produced a massive
following you know I get excited when
the doc looks like he's ready to
actually murder somebody his fame
impressive aim ups and downs aside one
thing that's underappreciated about
doctor disrespect is his ability to
juggle two personalities day in and day
out to his own admission guy beam and
doctor disrespect don't share many
personality traits guy is very literally
morphing into the doctor when he goes
live on Twitch every day do you have a
difficulty transitioning between
yourself and the doctors you're in
character for so long if we're so
intense amount of time is do you have
trouble being like okay now I'm just a
guy literally got no no we shut it down
we approach it as a business when we
tune into a stream every day we are
witnessing an impressively long piece of
performance art that webcam flicks on
and it's you and the screen and you
better be entertaining are you kidding
me Alex on an intro 300 million people
in the arena
good at your game of choice Bob and
handle it all while calm and collected
at first glance doctor disrespect it
looks wild just an aberration within the
normal tame world of twitch ladies and
gentleman trickle in these people
chubby-cheeked unathletic chubby gut
flappy Gump idiot punk kids that's where
I'm from
nobody gets in my way in this game I'm
the best in the game
[Music]
oh that's I'm talking about ha ha are
you kidding me huh thanks for watching
if you want more great content just like
this be sure to hit the subscribe button
commits to the champions club and
transform your life forever